merci de nous accueillir alors voir
assurer toutes les gens la maison n'est
pas dans un hôpital non c'est un plateau
de tournage manuel de la vie sauvage
puis en fait c'est un peu étonnant parce
que votre premier gros contre au secours
de béatrice ça se passe aussi dans un
hôpital oui mais en fait c'est la
première chose que j'ai dit en arrivant
ici je me sentais un peu l'inconnu
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça m'a rappelé way des souvenirs je
voulais vraiment vous rencontrer pour
parler de la série entre de droit que
j'ai beaucoup aimé il vous incarnez
l'idiot là dedans dans la réplique à
antoine kg antoine c'est pierre
lec'hvien qui aussi votre conjoint dans
la vraie vie comme oui mais non antoine
je viens avec un passé acquis afin que
tu acceptes mais ce que tu en penses est
évidemment présent chaque centime jours
comment on passe de la réalité à la
fiction pourront même tout seul c'est
parfait en fait parce qu'on peut
utiliser notre réelle complicité puis
notre plaisir à être ensemble notre
façon notre présence à être physiquement
l'un avec l'autre mais pour incarner ce
sont des situations qui nous concerne
absolument pas facile face il ya rien
qui se mélange il n'y pas de malaise il
ya pour nous c'est super agréable de
travailler ensemble parce que
ça passe et du
[Rires]
candidat ou non si vous tentez amis
retour en arrière vous êtes diplômé du
conservatoire d'art dramatique 2012
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à aller vers
ce métier là raymond paré marionnettiste
saccagé petit j'allais beaucoup sur les
plateaux de tournage visiter les
plateaux sur lesquels il travaillait la
marotte idier
pour être comme étant un outil
opératoire elle aussi en fait 35 ans
avant moi
me faxer pas un milieu qui met ses qui
m'étaient inconnues en même temps ils
sont pas nécessairement au coeur du star
système québécois exposent personnes en
plus mais je sais pas c'est comme juste
un milieu que j'ai toujours senti
accessible je dirais
[Musique]
moi je dis que j'ai jamais rêvé d'être
actrice parce que pour moi un rêve c'est
quelque chose d'inaccessible ou à peu
près de difficilement accessible du
moins qui pour moi ça n'a pas été une
femme ça me semblait pas quelque chose
qui était difficile à atteindre donc pas
un rêve dans ces termes là mais c'était
juste puisque j'avais envie de faire ça
si ça s'est déployée comme ça te dommage
que tu retombes petit rappel
de la junte
mais si mince espoir mais déjà on vous a
aussi vu dans district entier le rôle de
stéphanie mal au mont apparitions
sporadiques mais quand même ça doit être
toute une aventure oui et oui vraiment
apparitions sporadiques mais depuis ça
aussi quatre ans un choix de plus
je rôle dont je me fais beaucoup parlé
parce que c'est un job est un show qui
est extrêmement écoutez donc ouais je
sais d'être la femme dont je me fait le
plus parler je pense à la base mon défi
c'est de vulgariser que j'ai beaucoup de
mots compliqués d'autres termes
d'explication un petit peu exhaustive
des fois puis mon moi ce que je voulais
c'est que ce soit plate je voulais comme
rendre ce
comment dire un cheveu accessible
exactement et est intéressant et comme
un petit peu pas trop lourd avec eux
je pense que c'est de là que m'est venue
mon surnom de rayons de soleil
luc et chris van damme doucement cette
ligne là à dire à bruno
vous faisiez partie des signataires du
pacte a le projet de dôme n'est que
champagne que plus ou moins de succès il
ya déjà abandonné après deux ans comment
vous avez vécu cette expérience là d'un
peu importe dans quel projet c'est désir
là c'est manifeste la cause reste la
même il reste très importante fait
qu'après ce qu'est le projet réussisse
ou pas ou que ça fasse des vagues les
positives ou négatives on s'en fout le
bus et utilement de comme je disais
d'éveiller les consciences pi2 de
comprendre que c'est une urgence l'appui
que c'est pas c'est pas juste une
affaire de réseaux sociaux puis de
marché une journée par année avec des
pancartes le sait s'il se passe quelque
chose pour vrai qu'on peut pas le nier
[Musique]
j'entends au loin la cloche de la
reprise du tournage virginie ranger
beauregard merci beaucoup
merci merci